tu te souviens de la première fois que tu as rencontré
keith richards
[Music]
seulement très vaguement parce que nous étions à
peu près aussi grands que cette table
mais euh oui j'ai un vague souvenir de
certains disant playground
[Music]
bucket shop et cet autre gars
quoi  ça te rend fou de lui
euh je te dis quoi
la question est très difficile mais c'est
tellement compliqué après tout tu parles
de
gens qui se connaissent depuis
plus de 40 ans euh
tout ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on n'a tendance à
se fâcher qu'avec  les uns les autres quand
nous ne travaillons pas ensemble quand nous
travaillons ensemble
et nous sommes comme ça mais quand
nous ne le sommes pas alors nous avons tendance à trouver que vous savez
toutes les choses
qui sont différentes entre nous alors
c'est tout mais  ça ne me rend jamais vraiment en
colère il était vraiment vraiment en colère
si vous devez partir pour une
spéciale de trois ans  traiter
avec une pierre roulante laquelle prendriez-vous
[Musique]
comment avez-vous réagi en 77
quand clash juste des rumeurs disent plus d'
elvis plus de beatles plus de trucs en cours d'exécution
[Musique]
polissage stationnaire juste
est
[Musique]
euh
question stupide est-ce que tu préfères lennon ou
mccartney
[Musique]
qu'on t'a posé le plus souvent
euh cette question que tu viens de poser
combien de temps tu penses que tu vas
continuer à chanter
fais  tu penses que tu vas continuer pour
toujours ou tu penses que tu vas
arrêter
alors ça commence à l'âge de
20 ans et ça continue encore
maintenant c'est le plus courant que tu
arrives quand tu es sur scène pour penser à
John Lennon  la mort
très honnêtement j'y pense peut-être
quand je rencontre son fils de temps en temps
je m'en souviens mais
non sur scène je ne peux pas vraiment dire que je m'attarde
sur la journée de quelqu'un
[Musique]
ne travaille pas à l'étranger ça va marcher quoi de
négatif  chose diriez-vous de
vous-même le
japon passe paresseux
que changeriez-vous de vous  toi même si
tu avais la touche magique
pour ne pas être paresseux
sympathie
pour dieu
c'est un travail d'enfer
que répondriez-vous à vos enfants à la
question sur la cassonade ou la morphe soeur
j'ai dit écoutez-le vérifiez-le
ils sont là quand je l'écrivais il
n'y a pas de problème là-bas
[Musique]
bleu